bienvenue à tous sur lcp public sénat
c'est l'heure de parlement hebdo 45
minutes pour refaire l'actualité
politique et parlementaire avec au
rayonnement de chine bonjour bonjour
oriane et la question à la une cette
semaine c'est la déchéance de
nationalité
les parlementaires travaillent pour
tenter de trouver un compromis sur ce
sujet qui divise à gauche et à droite et
que françois hollande soit inscrire dans
la constitution en réponse aux attentats
de novembre l'état d'urgence prend fin
le 26 février faut-il le prolonger
comment en sortir c'est le débat qui
commence à agiter le parlement et puis
cette semaine on a beaucoup parlé de
primaires sont elles un parcours obligé
elle divise à droite comme à gauche pour
tenter de trouver le meilleur candidat
pour la présidentielle de 2017 est notre
invité cette semaine et jean christophe
lagarde
bonjour jean christophe lagarde ont une
bonne année merci bonne année à vous
vous êtes député de seine-saint-denis et
maire de drancy et président de l'udps
et y est nous allons refaire ensemble la
semaine politique et parlementaire
et on commence par la question des
primaires c'est au lundi c'est un appel
lancé à la une du journal libération qui
a agité la gauche une cinquantaine de
personnalités demandent l'organisation
d'une primaire de la gauche et des
écologistes jean baptiste daoulas les
primaires ouvertes de figure bien dans
les statuts du ps mais tout est fait
pour que le parti n'en organisent pas en
2016 premier verrou politique le ps
récuse l'idée d'une primaire de la
gauche qui se ferait sans lui
soit c'est la primaires de toute la
gauche
on va dire de macron à mélenchon mais je
suis pas sûr que tous les acteurs soient
d'accord
soit c'est une primaire pour départager
cécile duflot pierre laurent et jean-luc
mélenchon et vous comprendrez que les
socialistes ne soient pas deuxième
verrou sur le calendrier
françois hollande se laisse jusqu'à la
fin 2016 pour inverser la courbe du
chômage
sinon il ne sera pas candidat si après
cinq ans un président de la république
n'arrivent pas à atteindre l'objectif
qu'il s'est fixé pour être élu et bien
il ne peut pas être de nouveau candidat
à la responsabilité suprême du pays
conséquence françois hollande décidera
d'une éventuelle candidature bien après
la date limite pour organiser une
primaire ouverte
enfin jean christophe cambadélis a prévu
une diversion avec son projet d'une
grande alliance populaire à gauche il
prévoit une grande convention à
l'automne soit exactement au moment où
des primaires pourraient avoir lieu
tout est fait pour empêcher les
préparatifs de primaire qui aurait
besoin de plusieurs mois pour être
organisé
question simple jean christophe lagarde
françois hollande président de la
république doit-il se plier à une
primaire pour vous quel est l'intérêt du
débat en réalité le débat lancé par un
certain nombre de personnalités sur la
primaire à gauche c'est quoi c'est
d'abord le constat que françois hollande
a fait inscrire dans les statuts du ps
une règle qu'il entend ne pas appliquer
une fois de plus qu'il avait dit dans la
primaire de 2011 je crois que
naturellement à président de la
république il s'adressait à l'époque de
nicolas sarkozy devrait s'y plier mais
ajoutait-il je crois que monsieur
sarkozy ne soit pas qualifiée c'est sans
doute parce que françois hollande à la
crainte de ne pas être qualifié qu'en
réalité tous les verrous que vous venez
de décrire existe et puis troisièmement
quel est le fond du problème françois
hollande s'est fait élire sur un projet
sur un programme
il a au cours de son mandat échoué non
seulement à mettre en oeuvre ce
programme est il à la plupart du temps
renoncer à le faire en choisissant une
autre politique que celle pour laquelle
il avait été élu
évidemment qu'il ait un problème de
légitimité pour être candidat de
l'ensemble de la gauche et on voit bien
d'ailleurs je crois que là-dessus jean
christophe cambadélis a raison que les
verts les communistes ne serait pas prêt
à soutenir sa candidature même après une
primaire
donc il n'est pas le candidat naturel
pour vous il est naturellement pour
capable d'être candidat puisqu'il est
président de la république sortant et il
le sera s'était déjà pratiquement un an
qu'il est en campagne qu'on ne gouverne
plus réellement qu'on vide l'ordre du
jour du parlement qu'on n'oserait forme
plus dans notre pays
e donc il sera évidemment candidat est
ce que l'ensemble de la gauche
considérera que c'est son candidat
manifestement non est ce que vous pensez
qu'en 2017 jean christophe lagarde le
match entre la gauche et la droite va se
jouer au premier tour quand on regarde
le résultat des élections régionales
avec malheureusement une si forte
présence de l'extrême droite il ya très
fortes probabilités pour qu'au second
tour l'extrême droite soit présenté que
ce sont donc au premier tour que l'on
choisisse d'une part celui qui
affrontera l'extrême droite et je
l'espère celui l'emportera face à
l'extrême gauche le pire entre
guillemets moi je souhaite un changement
mais je veux pas un changement en pire
le changement qui verrait madame le pen
élu président de la république se serait
alors là pour le compte la déroute et
l'impasse totale parce que ce serait un
échec économique social diplomatique et
même morale pour notre pays alors
revenons si vous le voulez bien au sujet
le grand sujet de cette semaine l'emploi
puisque lundi toujours le gouvernement a
mis le cap sur l'emploi représentants
des syndicats du patronat a été reçu à
matignon pour tenter d'avoir des détails
sur le plan d'urgence qui sera bientôt
annoncée pour l'emploi et les amendes à
gaza il reste moins d'une semaine à
françois hollande pour finaliser son
plan d'urgence pour l'emploi
hier ce sont le premier ministre manuel
valls et la ministre du travail mme
myriam el khomri qui ont mené une
journée de concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux pour évoquer les
pistes prévues ouvrons certain nombre de
propositions concernant la prime à
l'embauché en tout cas tout ce qui
facilite davantage l'embauché notamment
pour les petites entreprises mais là
encore il ya des tailles et des mesures
à examiner aides à l'embauché formation
de cinq cent mille chômeurs insuffisant
pour le patronat qui a lancé l'offensive
sur le contrat de travail en réclamant
un cdi à gilles je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de faire en effet des mesures
sociales il faut partir de l'entreprise
une bûche et d'entreprises que le marché
du travail est bloqué en france on a
peur d'embaucher parce qu'on ne sait pas
eu son sujet françois hollande
détaillera son plan lors de ses voeux
aux forces économiques lundi pour la
ministre du travail
l'engagement du chef de l'état tient
toujours oui je pense que la courbe du
chômage
s'inversera en 2016 pour l'opposition
ces mesures servent à faire baisser
artificiellement le nombre de chômeurs
ce n'est pas un plan sur l'emploi
c'est un plan qui vise à retirer des
statistiques du chômage des demandeurs
d'emploi voilà il n'y a aucune
proposition en faveur de l'emploi
simplement ça vise à retirer des
statistiques des demandeurs d'emploi le
gouvernement entend montrer que l'emploi
reste une priorité
le 9 mars prochain myriam el khomri
présentera en conseil des ministres sa
réforme du code du travail alors 500000
formation en plus pour les chômeurs et
des mesures pour l'emploi est ce que
vous pensez que ce sont de vraies
mesures des mesurettes qu'est ce que
vous dites sur ce plan pourquoi ça ne
marcherait pas première chose qu'un
gouvernement qui est au pouvoir depuis
quatre ans en soit faire un plan
d'urgence pour l'emploi alors que depuis
le début du mandat et pendant sa
campagne électorale monsieur hollande 10
l emploi est ma priorité
si le sujet n'était pas aussi grave on
vient on en viendrait à espérer que ça
soit plus sa priorité parce qu'avec près
de six cent mille chômeurs de plus
depuis qu'ils gouvernent très
franchement sa priorité
c'est un échec c'est la première
observation parce que ça compte ça
commence à m'agacer cinéma qu'on nous
fait avec une succession de plans de
mesures qui visent à recours à retourner
d'une digue et ont inversé la courbe du
chômage alors que malheureusement
celle-ci ne cesse d'augmenter et ce au
moment où dans le reste de l'europe la
croissance et l'emploi sont repartis ça
veut dire qu'en réalité le problème il
est franco français a pas s'il va pas on
passe son temps dans le débat politique
français à dire que c'est l'union
européenne le problème sauf que l'union
européenne est en train de voir les pays
y compris qu'on était plus fort le plus
gravement touché par la crise que nous
de repartir et de redémarrer la france
reste en panne
mais ça c'est la responsabilité de
françois hollande et c'est certainement
pas avec deux catégories de choses une
mesurette qui est une prime de 2000
euros à lambeau gers et cette absurde
qu'est ce qui aujourd'hui bloc
réellement la capacité de créer les
emplois la compétitivité de nos
entreprises c'est pas un chèque une fois
qui permet de rétablir la compétitivité
son poids à ces mesures pourquoi
répondons non c'est de la com pourquoi
répondons à une mesure par une mesure
ponctuelle à un problème global qui est
le coût du travail qui est le temps de
travail etc et le contrat de travail
d'ailleurs à chaque fois qu'il parle de
réformer
le problème pour pour favoriser l'emploi
on observe qu'à chaque fois on évacue le
problème du temps de travail
on évacue le problème du contrat de
travail et on évacue le problème du coût
du travail et il faut baisser encore
plus les chefs aller plus loin dans la
baisse des charges je dis une chose
simple de notre système de protection
sociale et financer aujourd'hui sur le
travail des français et c'est ce qui
handicape la compétitivité c'est ce qui
crée de plus en plus de chômage et nous
devons changer radicalement la le
financement de la protection sociale qui
ne doit plus peser sur le travail du
fonds des français mais sur la
consommation c'est ce que nous disons
depuis des années évidemment ce pouvoir
n'a pas pu l'entendre c'est ce que nous
voulons aussi porté devant les français
en disant pour mettre à égalité un
salarié français et un salarié qui était
l'extérieur de notre pays et dont nous
achetons les produits parce qu on achète
beaucoup de produits d'importation on a
besoin que ce ne soit plus le travail
des français qui financent la protection
sociale des français
deuxième observation si vous le
permettez on se retrouve avec la sphère
des 500000 apprentis c'est du bluff et
c'est du bien ou c'est du bluff et c'est
du pipeau je le dis clairement la
réalité c'est que l'objectif de françois
hollande puisqu'il a dit vous montriez
avant qu'il ne serait candidat à
l'élection présidentielle que s'il a
réussi à faire baisser le chômage c'est
qu'il veut sortir ces cinq cent mille
personnes des statistiques de du chômage
aujourd'hui pardon d'être technique ils
sont en catégorie à s'ils sont en
formation ils sont en catégorie d et on
vous dit on vous dira vous voyez il ya
cinq cent mille chômeurs de nom de moins
c'est même irrespectueux pour les gens
qui vivent le drame du chômage
c'est de la manipulation statistique
politiques au mépris des du drame que
vente ces gens là qui serait temps que
le gouvernement se décide de tout
remettre à plat
mais comme je le disais tout à l'heure à
maintenant je crois 16 mois de
l'élection présidentielle
ce qu'ils n'ont pas fait au cours des
quatre dernières années ils vont pas s'y
mettre
puisqu'ils sont tétanisés par la future
candidature de monsieur hollande on va
passer homardiers jean christophe
lagarde mardi jour de reprise pour le
parlement
le parlement qui a donc repris mardi ses
travaux avec un agenda chargé dans les
mois à venir quels sont les grands
textes
au programme c'est ce que nous raconte
jean baptiste à daoulas premiers textes
importants à la fin janvier
la république numérique porté par axel
le maire une loi pour améliorer l'accès
à internet et protéger les données
personnelles
un intermède numérique avant un
programme largement consacré au
terrorisme et à la sécurité
la réforme de la constitution voulue par
françois hollande sera discuté au mois
de février avec le recours à l'état
d'urgence et à la déchéance de
nationalité inscrit dans la constitution
le texte devra être voté dans les mêmes
termes au sénat et à l'assemblée
nationale
autres projets de loi liés aux attentes
à une réforme de la procédure pénale
pour muscler les moyens de la police un
projet déjà contesté par les défenseurs
des libertés publiques
agenda chargé pour la garde des sceaux
elle qui espère boucler sa réforme sur
la justice du 21e siècle et dont le
projet de loi sur la justice des mineurs
n'a toujours pas été inscrit à l'ordre
du jour enfin les parlementaires se
pencheront également sur la lutte contre
le chômage avec une réforme du code du
travail très attendu le texte pourrait
également intégrer certaines mesures de
la future loi macron 2 afin d'éviter un
marathon de plus au parlement jean
christophe lagarde on reviendra dans
quelques instants longuement sur cette
révision constitutionnelle mais avant ça
est ce que françois hollande et
l'exécutif sont ils encore politiquement
en mesure de faire des grandes réformes
mais assure que non d'abord il ne le
souhaite plus j'observe que depuis mars
les textes qui sont présentés aux
parlements sont des textes secondaire
disons les choses clairement il n'y a
plus de mouvements de réformes et
d'ailleurs on n'a pas besoin de réformes
on a besoin de reconstruire des systèmes
qui aujourd'hui sont périmés obsolète
je le disais tout à l'heure pour la
protection sociale c'est vrai aussi de
l'éducation nationale souvenez-vous le
ministre de l'éducation nationale de
l'époque dont le nom m'échappe avait dit
on va réformer les rythmes scolaires
on a un petit peu changé la fin de
journée on a perturbé sa a coûté très
cher aux collectivités le
cal port et 1 il veut aussi transformer
les vacances où est passé encore cette
politique on voit bien que il n'y a pas
de vision
il n'y a pas de capacité de nouvelles
architectures essayer de nouvelles
architectures dans la france a besoin en
réalité et pas de ces bricolages
successifs puis en réalité maintenant ou
pour vocation à ne vexer personne à ne
fâcher personne de tangente à distribuer
quelques cadeaux notamment fiscaux avant
l'élection présidentielle
ccc c'est triste parce que la france va
perdre les seize mois qui viennent mais
le fait par exemple que certaines
mesures de la loi macron d'eux mêmes
dans la cour de vienne s'ajouter à la
réforme du code du travail pour vous
c'est aussi du bricolage mais même dans
la loi macro ce qu'est ce qu'il en reste
qu'est ce qu'il en reste le fait qu'on
ait le droit de concurrencer les trains
avec des lignes de bus
le fait que par dont on puisse passer de
cinq dimanches par an à 7 ou 12 dimanche
par an ou dix dimanches par an vous
pensez que sa réforme l'économie
française ce sont des mesures qui de mon
point de vue d'ailleurs ne devrait même
pas passer par la loi
c'est de l'or il arrive c'est quoi c'est
de là qu'il écrit ce qu'il ya dans les
réformes du code du travail
je viens de vous dire tout à l'heure il
est vécu a priori tout ce qui est
discussions sur le temps de travail
alors que c'est un vrai sujet tout ce
qui est discussions sur la nature du
contrat de travail les 17 contrats de
travail les dix-sept types de contrats
de travail existant qui déjà créer un
brouillard pour le chef d'entreprise qui
veut embaucher qui s'est pas auquel se
référer quelle est la sécurité ou
d'insécurité qu'il a avec tel ou tel
contrat de travail sur le fait qu'on
puisse dès le départ prévoir les
conditions de la sortie du contrat de
travail pour éviter qu on en fait on
s'enferme dans l'incertitude déploie des
prud'hommes et des jugements ultérieure
pendant des années des années ça ça
bloque
mais tout ça c'est évacué t en réalité
sa curieuse me remette cette réforme du
code du travail ce serait qu'une scène
sera j'appellerai même pas ça une
réforme la réalité c'est tout ce qui
pose problème tout ce qui est demandé
par qui parce qu'ils créent de l'emploi
les seuls qui créent de l'emploi sont
les chefs d'entreprise sont les
créateurs d'entreprise tout ce qui est
demandé est écarté et vous appelez ça
une réforme du code du travail
alors parlons d'un autre sujet d'une
autre réforme qui divise beaucoup et sur
lequel compromis semble difficile
j'étais déchéance de nationalité
annoncées puis confirmée par françois
hollande la mesure s'avère être un casse
tête pour le gouvernement explications
hamon bagarre à un consensus impossible
sur la déchéance de nationalité
c'est pourtant la mission confiée par
bruno le roux le président du groupe
socialiste à jean jacques urvoas et
dominique raimbourg
pour le moment les divisions sont
profondes rien n'a été tranché
c'est très difficile de vous dire avant
trouvez ce commun mais en train de
chercher une fois qu'on l'aura trouvé
on vous le dira dans l'hémicycle manuel
valls sera seul sur scène pour porter le
texte sans intervention de christiane
taubira
le premier ministre a réaffirmé que les
engagements pris au lendemain des
attentats seraient tenus le président de
la république annoncé une révision de la
constitution
nous avons également proposé la
déchéance de nationalité pour les
personnes condamnées pour un crime
constituant une atteinte grave à la
nation sans pour autant créer la
situation d'apatrides la déchéance de
nationalité pour les binationaux et non
pour tous contrairement à ce que
souhaitaient plusieurs voix de gauche
autre hypothèse pour ne pas diviser la
déchéance ne porterait plus sur la
nationalité mais la citoyenneté
ce sera donc sans doute soit une
déchéance de nationalité est étendue à
tous les français soit une des chances
de citoyenneté voilà en gros autour de
ces deux termes
je sors d'être plus fines dans la
rédaction en tout cas ce qui est certain
c'est qu'il y aura à la fois le souhait
des députés souci de respecter les
directions donné par le présent la
république un équilibre tout relatif car
l'opposition ne peut se passer du
soutien des républicains
prêt à voter le texte à condition bien
sûr de ne pas revenir sur l'inscription
de la déchéance de nationalité dans la
constitution la date d'examen n'est pas
encore fixée mais devrait avoir lieu au
plus tard début février pour ce sujet de
germain andrieu donc jean christophe
lagarde est ce que vous voterez la
révision constitutionnelle
écoutez moi d'abord je pense que ce
débat est très mal partie pardon même
dans la façon dont le sujet est présente
et vous dites cette divine non c'est un
débat c'est pas une division c'est
normal qu'il y ait débat chez les
républicains
au parti socialiste ça chez nous même
nos la division pardon c'est pas le
débat à l'ordre le débat est interdite
ça veut dire qu'on doit toujours être
d'accord tous ensemble surtout bah non
c'est pas comme ça que fonctionne la
démocratie d'ailleurs nous sommes les
représentants du peuple français le
peuple français il n'est pas d'accord
sur tout
deuxième chose moi je vais vous donner
mon sentiment personnel je suis pour la
déchéance de nationalité de tous les
terroristes condamnés
quelle que soit leur nationalité et je
voudrais faire observer la chose
suivante c'est qu'en france nous avons
un principe normal qu'ils aient
l'individualisation de
peine à chacun une peine qui peut être
différente mais l'individualisation de
la peine et peut pas se faire en
fonction de votre nationalité
et avoir deux types de sanctions ça tous
les frais à tous les français deuxième
observation il se trouve qu'on me dit ça
va ça va créer des apatrides d'abord on
en a le droit et pardon aujourd'hui dans
le droit français il il existe déjà des
mesures qui permettent de faire des
apatrides ce qui démontre d'ailleurs que
cette réforme constitutionnelle n'était
pas indispensable
troisième observation je ne vois pas
pourquoi un certain nombre de
parlementaires s'acharne à vouloir faire
en sorte que un terroriste puisse avoir
des privilèges dans le sa condamnation
simplement parce qu'ils ne seraient que
français celui qui a deux nationalités
n'aurait pas le même privilège que celui
qui serait français alors qu'en réalité
ces gens là ni tout ce qui représente la
france
toutes les valeurs qui nous sont chères
et qui nous font vivre ensemble et
qu'ils combattent ses valeurs et notre
pays
je ne vois pas au nom de quoi on peut
obliger le reste du peuple français à
dire que ces gens là qui nous combattent
qui le rejette et qui nie tout ce qu'ils
font que nous sommes français font
partie de la famille première chose mais
comme le dit le premier ministre
lui-même
c'est essentiellement symbolique parce
que ce sera de quasi nul effet
la deuxième chose et qui elle ne serait
pas symbolique et que nous devrions
faire et pour laquelle je milite c'est
qu'il y ait une peine d'indignité
nationale pour ceux qui sont partis à
prendre le terrorisme la barbarie la
guerre contre nous la haine de la france
est bien évidemment parce que ça nous
permettrait en l'occurrence de
conditionner leur éventuel retour quand
ils souhaitent revenir de l'encadrer
voire de le refuser et çà çà çà çà
aurait un effet très directe qui
permettrait de contrôler parce que un
français qui est parti à prendre là elle
la barbarie et le terrorisme dans ces
contrées de syrie et d'irak au sein des
rangs de neige par exemple il peut
revenir quand il veut et on me dit ah
bah on va les enfermer tu parles
qu'est ce qu'on sait réellement de leurs
activités là bas qu'elle noyant avons
nous de les incriminer jean christophe
lagarde clairement que vous avez pas
répondu clairement est ce que oui ou non
lui délivrera cette révision constitue
là encore pardon moi je réponds pas à
priori à une question quel sera le texte
final ne vous attendez vous avez je
n'attends pas il n'y aura pas de voix du
délit sont les idées du dès la première
des choses
et deuxième chose et je précise
d'ailleurs qu'une partie de ce que je
viens de dire est une position
personnelle mais le débat existe dans
notre famille politique comme dans les
autres
le texte sera comment dirais-je
définitivement adoptée par l'assemblée
par le sénat sans doute avec une navette
puisque je doute qu'on soit d'accord dès
la première fois je vous dirai à ce
moment là ce que sera la position de
l'ue ni moi je suis contre la politique
réflexe la république pavlovienne c'est
à dire on répond à une question avant
même de connaître quel est le fond de
l'air est ce que vous pensez que
françois hollande ira au congrès où il
aura difficilement la majorité des trois
cinquièmes ou est-ce qu'il choisira la
voie référendaire
moi je pense qu'il a il s'est engagé à
le faire devant le congrès il est
intervenue le 31 décembre en expliquant
qu'il faisait entre guillemets confiance
au parlement pour essayer de trouver les
voies de passage et donc c'est au
parlement que ça doit se traiter je
pense que chacun dans le moteur doit
être responsable
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils aient besoin
d'un référendum pour ça parce que alors
qu'il faudrait montrer une unité
nationale et un consensus pour faire
face aux terroristes qui qui nous
agressent un référendum par définition
ça divise et bien souvent les français
répondent à une autre question que celle
qu'il aurait posés on va passer tout de
suite mercredi
l'autre point de la révision
constitutionnelle c'est l'état d'urgence
en état d'urgence qui prendra fin le 26
février alors faut-il le prolonger
comment en sortir
écoutez ce qu'en dit le président de la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale jean jacques urvoas est entré
était une décision consensuelle en
sortir sera un acte plus délicat à
prendre je rappelle que vigipirate est
activée sous des formes diverses
depuis les attentats du rer de la gare
saint-michel de juillet 1995
je souhaite donc que nous puissions
sortir de l'état d'urgence là aussi en
faisant preuve de responsabilité
le moment venu arrêter l'état d'urgence
ne sera pas synonyme d'une moindre
protection des français puisque
l'essentiel de l'intérêt que nous
pouvions attendre des mesures
dérogatoires me semble à présent
derrière nous êtes vous favorable jean
christophe lagarde à une prolongation de
l'état d'urgence
moi je pense qu'on peut pas vivre tout
le temps dans l'état d'urgence mais j'ai
dit dès le départ en commission des lois
et à la tribune de l'assemblée nationale
que la difficulté que nous avons est la
suivante nous avons une menace
exceptionnelle qui nécessite des moyens
juridiques exceptionnel c'est la raison
de la création d
d'urgence mais cette menace
exceptionnelle elle n'est pas limitée
dans le temps ça veut dire qu'un certain
nombre de dispositifs juridiques
législatif répressif préventif qui
permettent de mieux lutter contre le
terrorisme doivent sortir du cadre de
l'état d'urgence pour venir dans notre
droit commun c'est ce qui est préfet
avec ce projet de loi j'observe sur ce
point nous avons enfin commencé à être
entendu parce que c'était une évidence
par dont l'assignation à résidence est
d'ailleurs on devrait peut-être en
parler dans la réforme constitutionnelle
aussi l'assignation à résidence pour
neutraliser des individus dont on pense
qu'ils peuvent participer ou nous
préparer la commission d'attentats
évidemment qu'aujourd'hui elle pose un
problème puisque c'est en réalité avant
qu'un crime soit commis qu'on agisse
enfin tous les français souhaitent et
c'est bien naturel qu'on essaye d'être
efficace avant les attentats plutôt que
de l'être et nos services de police le
son et de justice le sont
remarquablement après et donc je dis
simplement que le transfert d'un certain
nombre de mesures de l'état d'urgence
dans notre droit
c'est ce qui doit signifier la fin de
l'état d'urgence soit on est prêts
juridiquement pas ce qu'est ce qui est
prévu je ne sais pas comment ce sera
fait dans un mois pardon le temps
législatif pour adopter par exemple le
fait que l'assignation à résidence puis
c'est une mesure administrative prise
par le préfet qu'elle soit contrôlée par
les parlementaires pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de débordements et par la justice
administrative pour qu'il puisse y avoir
des recours individuels
ça ne se fera pas dans un mois donc si
on lève l'état d'urgence dans un mois on
sera plus en capacité de faire le suivi
entre guillemets d'un certain nombre
d'individus dangereux
voilà donc c'est quelque chose d'assez
simple je ne comprends pas pourquoi
l'état d'urgence date du mois de
novembre
le gouvernement attend du mois de
janvier pour entendre ce que je disais à
françois hollande dans son bureau à
l'elysée le 15 novembre lorsqu'il a reçu
les représentants des partis la menace
est exceptionnelle mais elle est durable
les mesures doivent être exceptionnelles
mais elles doivent intégrer notre droit
commun puisque notre droit commun c'est
ce qui est durable l'état d'urgence ne
peut pas durer tout le temps alors parmi
les menaces il ya cette agression cette
semaine d'un enseignant sur juif agressé
à la machette à marseille l'agresseur un
jeune chef de moins de 16 ans d'origine
kurde dit avoir agi pour le compte de
l'état islamique l'agression terroriste
a relancé le débat sur le port de la
kippa de députés l'ont mise en guise de
solidarité à l'assemblée écouter claude
goasguen aujourd'hui moi qui ne suis pas
juif j'ai mis une kippa
par solidarité car je ne peux pas
comprendre que dans un pays comme la
france qui est un pays des droits de
l'homme on puisse tuer des individus
pour sa religion ou essayer de les tuer
ce geste que je fais à l'égard des juifs
je le ferai aussi à l'égard des
musulmans ou des chrétiens vous savez de
l'esprit charlie a des inconvénients et
des avantages la religion ce n'est pas
la religion qui tue ce sont les hommes
qui tue et je ne voudrais pas que parce
que on a un ami l'agression de ce genre
on soit dans une régression historique
que les autres pays nous regardent avec
attention
faut-il retirer sa kippa par mesure de
sécurité au contraire le faire comme le
dit le député de votre parti meyer habib
mais parlons je n'ai évidemment aucun
commentaire à faire sur quelque chose
qui concerne la communauté juive
le débat sur le port ou le non port de
la kippa pardon il appartient à la fois
aux autorités du judaïsme en france et
en même temps je crois à chacun des
membres de la communauté juive
j'ai entendu différents arguments je
crois pas que la politique doit signer
là dedans
là où la politique à sa place là où
l'état sans devoir c'est qu'évidemment
il est inadmissible
invraisemblable que en 2016 dans notre
pays on doive avoir ce débat se cacher
ou pas pour assurer sa sécurité et le
devoir de l'état
c'est à la fois de tenir un discours de
fermeté absolue de laïcité c'est à dire
de faire en sorte que chacun puisse
croire ou ne pas croire suivre sa
religion de façon calme apaisé conforme
aux lois et sans être mis en danger le
trouble qui saisit la communauté juive
il doit être le trouble de l'ensemble de
la communauté nationale et de la même
façon si c'était demain un catholique ou
un musulman
cette atteinte là c'est la plus grave et
l'état son devoir c'est évidemment de
tenir ce discours
ces deux traquées de sanctionner et de
réprimer tout individu qui prônerait ce
type de discours ou qui évidemment ou
qui évidemment comment dirais-je
commettrait un acte comme c'est le cas
de l'adolescent en question
ces gens là ils doivent être neutralisés
temps par le discours que par les
sanctions qui doivent être adoptées on
entend ce que vous dites sur le fait que
vous ne voulez pas vous immiscer dans
les affaires de la communauté juive
néanmoins le président du consistoire
joël mergui demande aux parlementaires
de monde
l'exemple est de porter la kippa est ce
que vous pourriez le faire et à ce que
le parlement et au-delà les citoyens
doivent plus se mobiliser pour soutenir
la communauté juive ya deux questions
d'autres questions la première est ce
que je dois porter la kippa je ne le
crois pas je ne crois pas parce que si
ce n'est les fêtes tactique de diluer
les cibles entre guillemets potentiel
que je recherche
quelques tarés je vois pas l'intérêt
al'inverse est-ce que l'ensemble de la
communauté nationale doit se mobiliser
oui là pour le contre j'aurais souhaité
que assemblement républicains de toutes
les forces politiques soient organisés
c'est au rôle du gouvernement de le
faire pour montrer que la république
française ça ne peut pas être ça quand
un athée conte à qui on voudrait
contraindre entre guillemets qu'on
voudrait contraindre à une croyance à
chrétien un musulman un juif un
bouddhiste est agressé l'ensemble de la
population française qui doit se sentir
agressé pour une raison très simple
d'ailleurs c'est que dans la base de
notre vivre ensemble il y a
cette tolérance vis-à-vis de la croyance
individuel dès lors qu'elle n'entrave
pas la liberté de son voisin mercredi
gérard larcher était l'invité de la
presse parlementaire
le président du sénat a notamment dit
qu'il se méfiait des lois de pulsions
marie vraiment
quitte à apparaître à contretemps ou à
la traîne le président du sénat assument
la spécificité d'une institution qui
veut prendre son temps et pour illustrer
le tempo gérard larcher se livre même à
quelques confidences
il ya dans le bureau du président du
sénat une pendule très ancienne dans
lequel il ya le symbole du sénat le
miroir de la réflexion le serpent de la
sagesse il ya sénateur romain c'est très
ancien qui a le doigt comme ça sur la
tête et qu'elle est le symbole de cette
pendule prenez le temps avant de
construire la loire va de temps en temps
vous regardez la pendule gérard larcher
ainsi exprimé sa méfiance envers les
lois de pulsions rédigé à la hâte en
réaction à un événement et cette
méfiance exprime d'autant plus lorsqu'il
s'agit de réformer la constitution dans
les mois qui viennent les deux
assemblées devront en effet examiner la
constitutionnalisation de l'état
d'urgence
et introduire la déchéance de
nationalité le sénat examinera le texte
en seconde lecture pour là encore
prendre le temps de la réflexion quitte
à faire durer la procédure parlementaire
et comme le texte soit identique il peut
être identique après une navette est
d'ailleurs y'a pas de limites aux
navettes car en matière de réforme
constitutionnelle il peut avoir un très
grand nombre de la bête
donc il faut avoir en tête cela le
message envoyé au gouvernement est
limpide
inutile de se presser surtout quand il
s'agit de veiller aux libertés
fondamentales
un avis partagé par les sages devaient
tous bords c'est une vieille tradition
du sénat de quelques choix d'ailleurs la
couleur politique du gouvernement
il arrive que le sénat soit conservateur
dans beaucoup de domaines économiques et
sociaux mais dans domaine de liberté
veut cela a toujours été plutôt
protecteur protéger et exercer un
contrôle parlementaire en 2016 le sénat
compte bien faire entendre sa voix alors
gérard larcher a dénoncé les lois de ce
qu'il appelle les lois de pulsions
pourtant françois hollande est-il que le
temps législatif et est trop long encore
trop longs quel est le bon rythme et ce
n'est ce pas le rôle du parlement de
prendre un peu de temps pour y penser
c'est évidemment le rôle du parlement et
la difficulté qu'on a c'est que s'il ne
faut pas de l'oie de pulsions ce qu'on
multiplie au cours de ces dernières
années sous ce gouvernement comme sous
d'autres avant ce sont des lois de
communication la multiplication
législatives ne fait pas la garantie de
l'efficacité de la loi
au contraire il faut moins bon au
contraire bien moins de textes bien
moins de textes et moi je souhaiterais
d'ailleurs que le parlement siège moins
souvent pour qu'on n'ait pas cette
logorrhée et - législatives textes sont
longs et qu'il est qu'il aille sur le ou
sur les principes essentiels et pas dans
les détails ce qui est de l'ordre de
normalement au gouvernement et des
décrets et des bords de l'orb
réglementaire appliqué à la situation de
la réforme constitutionnelle
en réalité il ya deux parties dans cette
réforme constitutionnelle
une partie qui concerne la
constitutionnalisation de l'état
d'urgence c'est sans doute nécessaire
parce qu'il y avait eu un incident qui
règnent l'insécurité juridique potentiel
et puis il ya je le répète le débat sur
la déchéance de nationalité il n'était
pas nécessaire que ce soit
constitutionnel
elle existe aujourd'hui on pourrait la
modifier pour qu'elles soient plus
applicable par exemple je le dis
et pour améliorer le côté déchéance de
la nationalité ou indignité nationale
pour la rendre effective parce que là
encore pardon moi je suis quelqu'un de
pragmatique et qui veut que la ve
république soit efficace quand on nous
dit que les 1000 à 1500 personnes qui
sont parties en syrie en irak prendre
les armes contre la population de là-bas
d'abord et ensuite contre nous et que le
premier problème c'est leur retour
potentiel et qu'on ne fait rien et qu'on
adapte pas la loi il ya un problème
gérard larcher 1 dans sa conférence de
presse est également revenu sur la
réforme qu'il a mise en place et il a
annoncé une sanction financière pour
quatorze sénateurs trop absent c'est une
première est-ce que vous approuvez cette
mesure li se met au diapason de ce que
fait l'assemblée depuis 2008 ou 2009
je ne faut pas de beaucoup d'innovation
jeu françois hollande lors de ses voeux
aux parlementaires qui avaient eu
également mercredi a suggéré d'inclure
la réforme du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature et du parquet dans la
révision constitutionnelle est ce que
vous êtes d'accord je vous disais tout à
l'heure que le débat sur la réforme
constitutionnelle en cours
déchéance de nationalité état d'urgence
était déjà mal parti parce qu'on mélange
est un peu tout et n'importe quoi a
ajouté un nouveau texte me paraît
inopportun
mais par surcroît comment est-ce que ça
n'aboutirait le sénat en 2013 a déjà dit
son opposition à la réforme souhaitée
par le
gouvernement et donc ça veut dire qu' il
n'y aurait pas de majorité au congrès ça
sert à quoi de ressortir sur la table on
nous dit d'un côté faut faire consensus
on voit déjà des débats que ça peut
créer on sort quelque chose qu'il a pour
le compte fait 10 ans us la réforme du
csm
le changement de sa composition nous
sommes contre nous l'avons dit au sénat
nous l'avons dit à l'assemblée nationale
en revanche ce qui nous paraît possible
d'inclure et qu'il a pourrait faire
consensus
c'est une réelle indépendance du parquet
c'est à dire que désormais les
procureurs ne soit nommé que sur avis
conforme du conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
ce qui permettrait une indépendance
politique ne veulent pas en vis-à-vis du
pouvoir politique et qui nous
permettrait également de remplir nos
engagements internationaux vous savez
bien qu'on reproche à la france ce
système où le parquet peut obéir et
obéit souvent en réalité aux ordres du
ministre de la justice
quoiqu'elle s'en défende d'ailleurs on
va passer au jeudi tout de suite katia
jeudi didier guillaume le président du
groupe socialiste du sénat présentait
lui aussi ses voeux et il a défendu la
garde des sceaux christiane taubira qui
doit rester au gouvernement selon lui ea
le sujet précis là celui-ci de la
déchéance
elle s'est exprimée on connaît ses
positions de toute façon c'est le chef
de l'état l'avait dit à versailles c'est
le premier ministre qui au nom du
gouvernement sur un sujet aussi
important que celui ci défendra le texte
constitutionnel à l'assemblée nationale
et au sénat
donc moi je pense que christiane doit
rester pour vous christiane taubira at
elle encore sa place au gouvernement
quel ridicule et quel ridicule de la
part de la garde des sceaux et de la
part du président de la république il ya
deux solutions soit madame taubira tient
plus à ses conviction qu'à ses ambitions
et puisqu'elle est en désaccord avec une
réforme que normalement elle devrait
porter l samba c'est quoi le garde des
sceaux
le garde des sceaux c'est celui qui dans
son ministère à le sceau de la
république qui justement vient marquer
la constitution c'est elle qui est censé
garder ce saut et quand ya une
modification de la constitution c'est à
elle de faire ce travail et elle refuse
de le faire elle est en grève
alors parce qu'elle est en grève on va
mettre le premier ministre comme
remplaçants sur les bancs de l'assemblée
immobilisé là je croyais qu'il avait
autre chose à faire et d'autres urgences
sur l'emploi sur la lutte contre le
terrorisme et sans doute quelques autres
deuxième chose le président de la
république fait un discours applaudi à
la quasi unanimité de l'assemblée et du
sénat
il le fait à versailles au mois de
novembre la garde des sceaux qui ne
trouvent pas entre le mois de novembre
est le mois de janvier à redire fini par
dire je ne suis pas d'accord
elle n'a pas le courage de s'en aller
elle préfère ses ambitions plutôt que
ses convictions c'est au président de la
république au moins d'assumer ses
responsabilités et très clairement de
mettre fin à ses fonctions
vous vous rendez compte qu'elle va être
sur les bancs de l'assemblée nationale a
demandé aux parlementaires de droite du
centre et de gauche de voter un texte
tout en disant que ce texte allait
contre mais est ce que on a l'impression
qu'on revalorise la fonction publique la
fonction politique la fonction
ministérielle
je trouve ça lamentable jean christophe
lagarde on accueille sur ce plateau dont
jos est l'heure tout chez jim de la
loupe du scan alors jean christophe
lagarde c'est encore la période des
voeux est ce que vous avez une bonne
résolution pour l'année 2016 où j'ai une
bonne raison du show pour plein de
choses mais essentiellement pour ne pas
oublier ce que les français ont dit le 6
et le 13 décembre dernier vous souvenez
au lendemain des élections régionales
tout le monde disait on s'en souviendra
tout va changer les comportements etc
et puis depuis tout le monde a oublié
moi je ne veux pas oublier nous à lui
dit on veut pas oublier le 6 décembre
les français ont dit massivement qu'il
ne faisait plus confiance aux
responsables politiques qui ont déjà si
longtemps gouverné et à chaque fois
échoué et le 13 décembre ils sont venus
dire aussi en masse que pour autant il
ne voulait pas de l'extrême droite les
français attendent des équipes nouvelles
des idées nouvelles et les comportements
nouveaux
et c'est cela que je souhaiterais pour
l'année 2016 de faire en sorte qu' on
puisse sortir des faux débats de la vie
publique j'en essayer d'en soulever un
ou deux est rentré dans la réalité de ce
qui est nécessaire pour que notre pays
se redresse
c'est quand même ça la première des
choses et c'est certainement pas les
bricolages politique qui le permettrait
alors votre année 2005 vous avez
commencé début janvier
un déplacement à lille vous avez
rencontré xavier bertrand qui est le
nouveau patron de la région nord pas de
calais picardie vient de démissionner
cette semaine de l'assemblée pour
respecter ses engagements sur le non
cumul
c'est un modèle d'exemplarité politique
xavier bertrand mais j'y suis allé
d'abord parce que avec valérie létard
avec frédéric leturque avec brigitte
fouré lé maire d'arras mais la maire
d'amiens nous avons contribué à
l'élection de xavier bertrand
et nous avons aussi comment dirais-je
évité le pire dans cette région pour les
habitants qui déjà souffre beaucoup de
conditions économiques et sociales
difficiles et deuxièmement parce que
j'ai trouvé que xavier bertrand avec qui
j'ai par ailleurs d'excellentes
relations avec compris le message que je
viens de dire est que trop de gens dans
la vie publique ont oublié ce message
vous savez c'est trop facile de venir à
une élection de se faire élire de dire
j'ai compris tout oublier et moi je ne
veux pas que ça se passe comme ça je
crois que c'est quelque chose de plus
que je partage avec les américains il a
vraiment la cote en ce moment tout le
monde veut s'afficher avec lui même son
meilleur ennemi à l'ump ait fait un rush
et républicain qui est jean françois
copé qui a opéré son retour politique
cette semaine il va faire son premier
déplacement aussi à lille avec xavier
bertrand qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
comme comme comme rien rien je commande
vous trouve que vous savez je peux
expliquer mes choix je ne commente pas
le choix des hommes vous trouvez que son
son retour c'est une bonne chose c'est
une bonne nouvelle
puis qui a douté que jean françois copé
voulait continuer à faire de la
politique en personne bon pas grand
monde
est-ce que vous souhaitez que jean
françois copé soit candidat à la
primaire de l'egypte a souhaité me nomme
moi je suis pas son manager je suis pour
son coach m'en fiche
xavier bertrand encore lui il a réalisé
un bond dans les enquêtes d'opinion ce
qui n'est pas le cas du tout nicolas
sarkozy qui a perdu beaucoup de points
de popularité depuis les élections
régionales
il est dans une mauvaise passe dit de
lui jean pierre raffarin qu'est ce qui
cloche selon vous chez nicolas sarkozy
est ce que c'est un problème d'image
personnel est ce que c'est un problème
de ligne politique
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose qui ne va
pas vous demandiez quelles étaient mes
voeux pour 2016
bah je vais arrêter de parler des autres
et je vais parler de nous de ce que peut
apporter la vie politique je me fiche
pardon de dire je me fiche de ce qui se
passe au parti socialiste et je ne
m'intéresse pas ce qui se passe chez les
républicains
je dis simplement que nous avons
vis-à-vis des français un devoir c'est
de leur expliquer comment on peut
relancer la france comment on refonde un
modèle économique
sociale et son système de protection
comment on transforme la relation que
nous avons au travail alors que par
exemple nous avons une un bouleversement
devant nous dubé risation de
numérisation de robotisation qui va tout
changer et qu'on peut pas rester
immobilisé parce qu'on va encore se
planter comment on fait en sorte que
l'éducation nationale cesse de produire
année après année des exclus de la
citoyenneté et des exclus du travail
c'est à dire qu'elles ne permettent plus
à chacun de pouvoir progresser dans sa
vie en fonction de son mérite ça fait 30
ans que ça dure c'est plus intéressant
pardon de vous le dire que la cote de
popularité de monsieur sarkozy ou le
retour de monsieur par l'élu délit alors
parlons lieu d y ait la guerre la
primaire puisque ah ben c'est bon on
revient dans la politique politicienne
j'ai essayé de parler d'autre chose en
même temps une question cruciale pour
votre parti en 2007 vous l'avez évoqué
lors de vos voeux cette semaine la
question doit être tranchée par un vote
des adhérents de votre parti au mois de
mars les positions sont assez variés
entre les différentes composantes de liz
est il parti radical est plutôt contre
une participation est vrai plutôt une
candidature indépendante
d'autres comme hervé morin 10 attention
le front national est très haut il va
falloir qu'on ait un seul candidat de la
droite et du centre en 2017
quelle est votre position j'imagine que
vous allez dire que vous allez faire la
raison mais est ce que est ce que vous
avez une position personnelle ou est ce
que vous attendez le vote des adhérents
pour justement tranché annoncé votre
veste bien sûr que j'ai une position
personnelle mais j'ai dit une chose
lorsque j'ai été élu président du 10/01
que le débat s'ouvrira en janvier je
louvre cette semaine et la semaine
prochaine pour que dans toutes nos
fédérations chacun discute 2 que ce
débat serait ouvert qui ne serait pas
fermé et je ne vais pas en tant que
président dudit le verrouiller à benicio
en donnant ma position et en faire une
affaire personnelle
je la donnerai le moment venu mais la
détermination c'est que toutes les
options sont sur la table
la vocation du dit lorsque nous l'avons
créé avec jean louis borloo c'est de ne
pas laisser les français enfermés entre
le parti socialiste et les républicains
en truites alternance qui en trente cinq
ans n'ont pas permis à la france de
progresser de se redresser
je pense que nous pouvons et que nous
devons porter notre message devant les
français les militants choisiront et
c'est pour ça que je parle de politique
politicienne façon dont nous le
porterons et j'insiste sur une chose
la primaire telle qu'elle a été
aujourd'hui imaginé par les républicains
c'est en fait le moyen de se trouver un
chef parce qu'ils n'ont pas de chef
évident légitime qu'ils partiraient à la
prochaine élection présidentielle si la
primaire l'option étant ouverte
si la primaire est un débat entre
républicains pour et par les
républicains c'est évidemment sans nous
si et pour éclairer le choix de
primaires à droite et du centre ouais
enfin tant que le sang prepon dans ces
primaires de la droite deuxièmement si
ils souhaitent une primaire comme vous
dites de la droite et du centre
il faut d'abord que la compétition soit
honnête sincère loyal il faut qu'il y
ait des vrais débats
j'entends déjà dire que certains
voudraient qu'il y ait pas de débat s'il
n'y a pas trois affaires dont il n'y a
pas trois ou quatre débats là dedans je
vois pas à quoi ça ressemblerait il faut
évidemment des gages de la part de la
droite les républicains
écoutez moi jusqu'au bout il faut
évidemment que comment dirais-je gens
puissent participer aux conditions
d'organisation de la primaire qu'on y
fixe aussi des conditions programmatique
il ya des différences entre nos familles
politiques faut-il d'assumer mais c'est
quoi la primaire s'il ya un bloc qui est
la primaire
la présidentielle la législative c'est
en réalité la préparation d'une
alternance pour que nos militants
puissent se prononcer en connaissance de
cause
faut-il que nous discutions et je vais
le faire dans les prochains jours avec
les républicains de la façon qui le
conçoivent si on n'est pas d'accord je
ne vois pas comment il peut y avoir de
prix mais qui parce qu'il ya une chose
que nous refusons et que je refuse
absolument c'est qu'on renouvelle
l'expérience de 2007 à 2012 où les
républicains décidés et où les
centristes même quand il était ministre
n'avaient pas leur mot à dire
est ce qu'il le sujet en l'occurrence
c'est une commune alternance elle se
construit la primaire n'est qu'un des
éléments de cette alternance éventuels
qui doit y avoir un accord sur des
programmes et des places aux
législatives est ce que c'est une
question qu'on doit déjà vous devez déjà
abordé à le guen évidemment avant
d'annoncer ma décision a évidemment un
pacte de gouvernance qui comporte les
conditions d'une compétition qu'ils
comportent
comment dirais-je des limites
programmatique qui sont acceptables par
les intéressés imaginez par exemple que
le décès je voudrais juste terminée
imaginez par exemple le candidat qui
sortiraient de la primaire serait
quelqu'un qui est contre la construction
européenne vous croyez que ça peut
convenir aux centristes et notre
particulièrement aux électeurs sans
donc et ensuite évidemment un équilibre
politique législative notamment qui doit
être envisagée c'est un bloc et donc
avant que les militants fassent le choix
faut connaître les conditions de ce
choix mer et merci tu déjà merci qu'elle
donne au parlement at on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine très bonne journée